Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the American science
fiction comedy film called “Idiocracy.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year
2005.
At the beginning of the movie, it is narrated
that human evolution is at a turning point.
Most science fiction theories predict that
the future of humans is going to be more advanced
with smarter people.
But because humans are already on the top
of the food chain their evolution takes a
turn for the worse.
People grow dumber with time.
In such conditions, the U.S. Army librarian
Corporal Joe Bauers is approached by his seniors
proposing him to be a part of an important
experiment.
Joe, who had planned to stay a librarian till
retirement is annoyed but he has to follow
the orders.
Then, we are taken to a private meeting between
some high ranking military officials.
General Collins presents his ideas to the
other officers.
He says that the scientists have invented
a human hibernation pod that can preserve
human beings for an indefinite amount of time.
It is so humans can preserve their finest
men at their prime and revive them in the
time of need.
They have chosen Joe to be the first test
experiment because he is the most average
man in the military and has no immediate family.
Similarly, they also required a woman for
the experiment but they didn’t have a perfect
fit in the military.
Hence, Collins chooses a prostitute named
Rita.
He shows the officers pictures of him and
Rita’s manager Upgrayedd partying together
making everyone in the room uncomfortable.
He ends the presentation by saying that the
subjects will be put into the pods tomorrow
and the experiment will go on for a year.
Since the experiment is highly classified,
the officials present in the room aren’t
allowed to share the information with anyone.
The next day, Joe and Rita are together in
a waiting room.
Joe introduces himself and asks Rita what
sector she is from.
Not wanting to reveal that she is a prostitute,
Rita says that she is a painter.
Then, both of them are put on IV and into
two human hibernation pods.
Rita freaks out and tries getting up but Joe
assures her the scientists know what they
are doing.
He tells her they will only be inside for
a year so it will be perfectly fine.
At last the two are sealed inside the pods.
However, things start to go wrong when officer
collins is arrested in an attempted prostitution
ring.
Along with him, Upgrayedd is also arrested
for being the ringmaster of a prostitution
ring.
Hence, now no one is there to look after the
hibernation pods.
Because of a scandal, the military base is
closed and the building the pods are in is
demolished.
Joe and Rita lie dormant in the pod as the
years pass.
Although things look bad for the two, they
are even worse for mankind.
Humans begin to evolve stupider at a frightening
rate.
The chart of average intelligence goes downhill
with time.
Some people have high hopes that genetic engineering
and science will be able to correct this trend
of evolution, but the smartest scientists
in the world are focusing on stupid experiments
like trying to reverse hair loss and prolong
erections.
In the meantime, the population explodes and
intelligence continues to decline until the
year 2505.
All these years, people aren’t able to solve
basic human problems like garbage disposal.
So the garbage has been stacked for centuries
with no plan whatsoever.
This creates the great garbage avalanche of
2505.
And one day, a massive garbage landslide causes
Joe's hibernation pod to end up in a random
house.
Joe gets out of the pod dizzy and confused.
The person in the house is named Frito Pendejo.
Frito completely ignores a pile of garbage
and a stranger in his house and continues
watching weird shows on TV.
He only gets up to ask Joe to not make a noise.
We see that his couch also has a toilet so
he wouldn’t have to get up time and again.
He then kicks Joe out of the window.
The outside world seems confusing to Joe and
he says to himself so much has changed in
just a year.
But little does he know he has entered the
year 2505.
He sees a group of people by the side of the
road who talk in slang and grunts.
Joe is able to understand them but when he
speaks like his normal self, they call him
slurs and chase him away.
A confused Joe also feels dizzy so he decides
to go to a nearby hospital.
There, he goes to the reception and tells
her he is from the army.
The woman doesn’t understand anything and
just presses one of many buttons on her desk.
A voice asks Joe to proceed to the diagnostic
area on the right.
Confused, he goes to drink some water from
a water fountain but it supplies an energy
drink called the Brawndo instead of water.
When Joe asks a bystander where he can drink
water, the man laughs at Joe for wanting to
drink something they use in toilets.
It is revealed that everyone in the world
uses Brawndo to bathe, drink and for daily
activities, while water is only used in toilets.
Then, he goes to the diagnostic area where
he has to put plugs into his mouth, ear, and
anus.
The health professional mismatches the plugs
that he already put into specific areas.
A disgusted Joe completes the procedure and
is sent to a doctor.
While waiting he sees the date 2505 written
on a magazine but dismisses it as a misprint.
The doctor arrives and answers all of Joe’s
questions about his health with “kick ass”.
He also declares Joe retarded and asks him
to pay a fee of five billion dollars.
Just then, Joe notices 2505 written on the
bill.
He finally realises that he has actually been
inside the pod for five hundred years.
Joe almost doesn’t believe it and goes to
the window only to be surprised to see the
current condition of the city.
Buildings are collapsing onto each other and
some are held together by ropes.
In addition, the city is filled with garbage.
Meanwhile, the doctor freaks out because Joe
doesn’t have a citizen tattoo on his wrist.
Joe panics and runs away from the hospital
while the doctor calls the police on him for
not paying his hospital bills.
A voice narrates that Joe has woken up to
a world in crisis.
The economy is in deep neglect, a great dust
bowl has ravaged all food supplies and the
number one movie in the country is called
Ass.
He goes to watch the movie that won oscars
only to stare at someone’s behind for ninety
straight minutes.
At night, he is arrested for being “unscannable”
and taken to a court.
There, he is given a lawyer who happens to
be Frito Pendejo, the guy that Joe met the
first in 2505.
Frito makes fun of him as everyone in the
court laughs.
Joe presents his case sensibly and and explains
why he is unscannable but the lawyers and
judge just laugh at him.
At last the Judge declares him guilty and
sentences him to jail.
Meanwhile, Rita also comes out of the pod
and is trying to contact her manager and boyfriend
Upgrayedd.
She is unsuccessful as the phone asks her
for two thousand dollars to contact him.
Just then, she is approached by a man who
she tricks and gets his money.
At the same time, Joe is taken to an automated
tattoo place where the citizens are given
the identification tattoo that makes them
“scannable”.
The machine asks him his name but Joe starts
to explain that he is not sure what is going
on.
Because of this, the machine reads his name
as “not sure” and tattoos it on his wrist.
The people around him also start calling him
Not Sure.
Then, he is taken to an amplitude and IQ test
and asked questions about basic addition.
Joe answers all of them correctly and is surprised
to see people around him not being able to
identify shapes.
After that, he is taken to the prison.
He finally begins to realise that everyone
in the current world is stupid.
So, he tells the guard he is supposed to get
out of jail today.
The stupid guard lets him walk away but the
alarms catch that an inmate has ran away and
the police chase him down the streets.
Joe somehow gets away from them and goes to
Frito’s place again.
He believes that someone has created a time
machine within the past five hundred years
and asks Frito’s help in getting one.
Frito doesn’t agree on helping Joe but Joe
tricks him by saying that he will give him
eight billion dollars for his help.
Eventually Frito reveals that he knows where
the time machine is.
Just then, the police knock on the door looking
for Joe.
The two run away through the window and drive
to the museum.
On their way they meet Rita who is still scamming
the same guy.
Rita gets in the car and is worried that Upgrayedd
will come looking for the money she owes him,
still oblivious that he is already dead.
As they drive, something from outside the
car scans Joe’s wrist and the police are
notified of his location.
The car’s battery runs out and they get
out of it.
Right after, the police approach the car and
fire at it.
Soon, a bunch of people join and start to
fight.
Joe, Frito, and Rita run away in hopes of
getting to the time machine.
Joe then takes the two to Costco which is
now the centre of all trades.
He even claims to have studied law in Costco.
As they wait for the metro, Rita goes to the
bathroom.
Before she returns, Joe’s wrist is accidentally
scanned and the whole place is alerted of
a criminal’s presence.
The metro arrives and Frito gets on it but
Joe waits for Rita only to be caught by the
police.
However, this time, he is taken to the white
house instead of prison.
There, a confused Joe meets the president
Camacho and his secretaries.
Camacho makes fun of him saying that he thought
Joe’s head would be bigger because he is
smart.
It turns out that the IQ test Joe took in
the prison surprised everyone because he had
the highest IQ they had ever seen.
Hence, because of his intelligence, the president
makes Joe the new secretary of interior.
To Joe’s surprise, they also declare him
the smartest man in the world.
Everyone then goes to the house of representin’
where the president announces that the problems
of food scarcity and dust storm will be solved
by their new secretary of interior, Mr. Not
Sure.
He also promises to pardon Joe’s prison
time if he solves the problem.
After that, a cabinet meeting is held where
the secretaries ask Joe to say something smart.
Joe says some random complicated words making
them believe that he is infact smart.
Then Joe asks Frito to draw a map of the location
of the time machine until he distracts the
secretaries.
Later, he takes them to a field where crops
are supposed to be grown.
He also asks them to get Rita because she
might be able to help them with the crops.
Now, everyone is at the field where Frito
secretly hands Joe the map.
At the same time, Rita arrives there.
Joe takes her aside planning to run away using
the map.
But his plan fails when he sees that Frito’s
map is just a line.
Then, Joe realises that people have been watering
the crops with the energy drink brawndo.
He holds a cabinet meeting to start using
water instead of brawndo.
The secretaries think his idea is atrocious.
So, instead of reasoning with them, he simply
tells them that he can talk to the plants
and they want water.
Joe is unknown that the energy drink had caused
salt to develop over top soil which killed
plants and caused the dust storms.
Hence, he is actually solving their problems.
For a few days everything goes as planned.
But soon, the energy drink brawndo’s stocks
drop to zero because of the decreased production.
This leaves half the population unemployed.
They riot outside the white house.
The news announces that Joe is taken to court
for making people unemployed and is proven
to be guilty.
He is sentenced to one night in rehabilitation.
In the new world, rehabilitation is when a
criminal is chased by a large truck in an
arena as a crowd of audience cheers for the
truck.
The rehabilitation mostly ends with the criminal’s
death.
Joe is taken to the arena while Rita sadly
returns to the white house, ready to go to
the time machine with Frito.
The rehabilitation is broadcasted on national
television.
Joe is chased by a massive killing turck as
he drives around in a small car.
Just then, Rita notices a rose plant growing
outside.
She realises that Joe’s idea to water the
plants had worked and asks Frito to take her
to the arena.
She plans to broadcast the crops on the television
so Joe’s punishment would be pardoned.
Meanwhile, Joe is still trying to save his
life from the death truck.
Rita reaches there on time and bribes a cameraman
to go with Frito and film the growing crops.
She then goes to the monitoring room and takes
over the control panel.
Frido finally gets to the field and films
the crops.
The clip is broadcasted on the large screen.
Seeing this, president Camacho saves Joe from
being killed and pardons his punishment making
the crowd erupt in cheers.
Now, everyone is at a frat party in the white
house.
Rita reveals that she doesn’t want to return
home because she likes the future better.
Joe is surprised but doesn’t force her to
come with him.
The two say their last goodbye, but before
Joe leaves, the president calls him on the
stage and declares him the new vice president.
Everyone looks at Joe with hopeful eyes making
him agree to stay in 2505.
Then, one person calls the “time machine”
a stupid ride.
Frito takes a confused Joe to the machine
and it is finally revealed that the time machine
is actually a children’s ride.
The scene cuts a few months later, when Joe
is elected as the president of the United
states and Rita becomes his wife and the first
lady.
Under his leadership, a new era dawned and
people hoped that humans could once again
be smart.
He even has three kids with Rita who are said
to be the smartest kids in the world.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.